from hollywood hotshot to hollywood has
been and back again acting legend mickey
roulette defies cancellation a stunning
and sometimes scandalous career spanning
40 years including a lost decade in the
hollywood wilderness he's fought and
feuded with the titans of tinseltown has
an opinion on almost everything and i'm
delighted to say he joins me now live
from los angeles mickey great to see you
great to see you i heard you mustering
before we went to the commercial break
what does uncensored mean and i would
say you you are an uncensored man
well
i'm my own man
how have you been i've interviewed you
numerous times over the years you look
in great shape
yeah i uh
the covey thing actually
helped me out a little bit because i was
able to go around all the different
sports shops and get all the workout
equipment i needed for close to a year
and a half so i did nothing but like
train for
you know
45 minutes twice a day and did a lot of
reading and
soul searching and
i had kind of tried to figure uh well
i was working on a game plan for the
third chapter
and
[Music]
trying to go over
all the mistakes i made the first two
chapters and
not making them again because it just
made life difficult for me you know and
i've said this before you know
about
over 20 years ago i was sitting in my
i was in london actually at blake's
hotel
sitting sitting in uh
on the phone with richard harris and
richard gave me some really good advice
about he said mickey man
he said listen
you can't
beat them there's too many of them and
they got too much money and they've got
he says you just gotta pull back and
and i got off the phone with richard and
i thought nah
i'm gonna do it my way and you know and
i made a big mistake because
i really
richard had been there before me and i
really
was an [ __ ] not to take richard
sound good advice that he gave what have
you learned about yourself mickey in
this in this sounds a fascinating
journey you've been on here what have
you learned most about yourself
well you know the biggest thing was i
i came from a very
shameful upbringing and it was very
violent and very physical abuse and
mental
and i
when i left home at like 14 or 15
i didn't realize
i was so happy that
the physical
pain was over because that was
horrifying
that went on for nearly 10 years but i
didn't realize that
it was going to
[ __ ] me up
in my head my way of thinking my way of
dealing with people because i
you know you have a choice when you're
when you
when you're abused
physically
uh at the time i wasn't thinking about
it mentally uh
you you
there comes a time
and it happened when i was about 14.
and when you're living in
shame it's a
there's nothing worse than that so
you got two choices
you either live in shame
and you become like a broken
soul a broken person
or you get hard
and
i chose to get hard
not by choice just by survival and
as the years passed and
i messed everything up that i tried to
accomplish
you know i
i take the blame for it because
by me getting
hard
with everything and everybody uh
alienated me from
i became as my therapist told me
a scary person to deal with
and i didn't know how to turn the off
switch
off and have you learned mickey have you
learned how to turn that off now
i've learned well it's interesting i
went to therapy for 23 years and i
i didn't ever think i would
but the therapist said to me one day he
said after about
three or four years
out of the 23 i went
he said you have absolutely no regard
for
repercussions or accountability
he says that's just not in your dna
and i realize with dealing with
people who deal from an authoritarian
place
producers who think that they can
treat you a certain way because they're
the ones with the money and the power
they finally ran into a cat they can
didn't give a [ __ ] about their money
you've got to watch your language mickey
i'm sorry i'm afraid i have to apologize
when you do that but i understand why
you feel this way yeah i i apologize for
it i'm just saying
you know people have money in power they
really feel that they have a
this thing where they can
treat you a certain way
i made a decision
a long time ago when i was 14
that
i got to be a man
and i had to be a man of 14.
and later on but as the years went by
even with the success
and the and the destruction of my career
it was always important for me
because of where i came from
to be a man first
and then active second
i you know i i interviewed just before
the wrestler came out and it was an
incredibly powerful interview because
you've been in the wilderness for so
long then
and then suddenly the wrestler came
along and propelled you back
to the top again
what was that moment for you
i'm back i'm back in the wilderness
after the wrestling
you're not really though are you i don't
think you're not not not really because
what i learned to do
was
i wasn't gonna let anyone put me on the
shelf
yeah all right
because i want you to hate me
i've got enough ability and i've got
more ability than most doctors that are
walking around
and if i could just behave myself
there's a lot of young up-and-coming
directors
that aren't afraid of what
how i used to be perceived
when you see when you see mickey when
you see someone like tom cruise
you know grossing a billion dollars with
top gun
maverick the sequel
35 years or so after the first one what
do you think of that
that doesn't mean [ __ ] to me the guy's
been doing the the same
effing part for 35 years you know
there's you know i mean
i got no respect for that
right i don't get i don't give it nah
that's r yeah really brother i don't
care about money and power i care about
when i watch al pacino work and chris
walken and and de niro's early work and
uh
richard harris's work and ray winstone's
work those are the kind of that's the
kind of actor i want to be like monty
cliff and you know brando back in the
day and
uh a lot uh a lot of guys that just
tried to stretch his actors and be the
you don't think tom cruise is a good
actor
i think he's irrelevant in my world
fascinating mickey hold it there we're
going to take a short break and we'll be
back after the break to talk to you
about i want to talk about cancer
culture and about vladimir putin welcome
back i'm with mickey raw mickey i want
to ask you about cancel culture what do
you make of this weird phenomenon that
we now will have to operate under
about what cancel culture
i have i i don't have any opinion on all
that
what do you think when you see people
being cancelled for having an opinion
that happens all the time it's nothing
new but do you think he's right
uh
i would have to be given a specific
uh case well i'll give you one so macy
gray the singer came on my show last
week and said what her definition of a
woman was and she got so much abuse
for her honest opinion that she had to
go on the today show in america and
effectively back down on her opinion
which i thought was ridiculous there's
an example of the kind of mentality i
don't i don't think anybody should have
to
uh apologize for what their personal
opinion is on
on any matter
uh unless their personal opinion is very
narrow-minded and it's going to hurt
other people
you said some interesting stuff about
vladimir putin after you met him in 2014
you wore a t-shirt with his
his picture on it um yeah that okay that
was 2014. i know that's what i said yeah
so i wanted to ask you whether i no i i
just want to make that clear okay i went
over there 2014.
and
he there it was some sort of event where
some
uh entertainers from the states came
over and he was dancing with sharon
stone and he was he actually was singing
a song on a piano
and then he invited me specifically to
go
to his hometown in st petersburg
to visit a uh home
uh
that
took care of little tiny children that
had uh
kind of incurable cancer
and uh
that was
really
heartbreaking to go to
and uh i was talking to all these little
kids and i i remember i gave a rosary of
mine
to one of the little girls
um
and i looked over at
uh vladimir
and i could see somebody
that was genuinely concerned
about
where we were
and
someone who
was empathetic and
he was there
for a sincere reason
how do you square that mickey with the
guy we see now illegally invading
ukraine and bombing little children to
pieces every single day
that's the thing that
blows my mind because it's like
it's like two brother countries and it's
like i don't understand what he wants
and it's like
not only combatants are getting killed
but old people are getting killed young
people are getting killed schools are
getting targeted hospitals are getting
targeted you know and all that shit's
not right you know i saw
uh
i saw a guy an image of a man who was
looking at a hole in a ditch
and he was looking for
and i put myself in his position he was
looking for his brother
and
uh
that
kind of struck home with me
and bothered me a lot and made me think
he's doing really terrible bad things
and
i wish some kind of little bell would
ring in his head or his heart
and he'd wake up and just stop all this
[ __ ] and then
i saw a picture of a man
an old man
laying shot on him on a bicycle and an
old woman shot on a bicycle
but the image that bothered me the most
was
i saw this old man
holding a
a little gray kitten
and the mil the old man survived his
house being bombed
and
he lost five family members
and the only thing he had
kind of hard for me to talk about it the
only thing he had was this little great
kitty
and i
i looked at that image a [ __ ] image
sorry
and i i said
how can i have anything to worry about
losing a movie
somebody saying bad [ __ ] about me
or i'm having a bad day and i'm looking
at this old guy holding a little kitty
that crawled out from the rubble
and that's all he had
and he lost five family members and
ever since that day
horrendous ever since that day
i've said prayers for that man and
for the two old people i saw on the
street and
mickey i'm gonna have to i'm going to
have to end the interview but what i
want to do if it's okay with you i want
to carry it off whatever they want to
say
what i want to say we're going to carry
on
we'll carry on vicky after we come off
air and i'll record it for later in the
week okay all right